hey everybody Michael Knowles here and I
am very excited to tell you about all
the new pronouns that we are expected to
use in our crazy modern culture this
video is brought to you by geniusell
Moore from them in just a little bit but
first let's take it away you know I am a
huge fan of language and the perversions
and abuses of language take it away with
the pronoun tick tocks well how do I
call myself gay if my pronouns are he
they and I'm dating a girl
well
[Music]
what scarf
Ace
I can say that louder for y'all on the
back if you want me to too you can
identify as any gender you want and use
whatever pronouns make you feel most
comfortable meaning you can identify as
a male but use she her pronouns if
that's what you like I identify as just
me whatever that is I'm just me baby and
I like to use gay as an umbrella term
like how queer people use queer for
themselves because that's what feels
right to me so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my favorite one I've ever seen
from the whole rainbow LGBT thing
because it's the logical conclusion of
it or the illogical conclusion but it
does flow naturally from their premises
which is if
your identity does not need to be in all
ways Tethered to reality then it doesn't
need to be in any way Tethered to
reality if if a man can say I I am not
obligated to behave like a man I'm a man
but I'm going to act in certain ways
like a woman or like a jackrabbit or
whatever then The Logical conclusion is
you have no obligation to associate with
reality in any way so the conclusion is
to begin
my pronouns don't need to match my sex
because my gender expression is
different than my sex but then the more
concentrated version of that is my
pronouns don't need to match my gender
and then you say my pronouns right now
don't need to match my pronouns five
seconds ago five seconds ago the person
said my pronouns are he and they but
then through the video the person says
No my only pronoun is me not even I not
even the nominative only the accusative
me I'm just me baby but of course the me
means nothing because if you Embrace
these kind of ideologies then you you
give away your entire identity because
the man who can be everything
is also the man who is nothing and this
person I don't know if it's a man I
don't know if it's a woman I don't know
but it's a very confused person but
there is nothing about the identity to
hold on to in this pursuit of total
Liberation this person has liberated
himself
from himself here's how to use a air
pronouns these are Neo pronouns AKA new
pronouns one of the many awesome options
out there for people who don't relate to
the traditional societal pronouns of he
him she her or they them lots of people
use a air pronouns so let's practice
using them in a sentence a is so fun to
hang out with I only met air recently
but Air energy is radiant and I know a
is going to be a great friend so there
already is a neutral pronoun the neutral
pronoun is he and him
and his
that's what until at least very recently
the Oxford English Dictionary called the
the gender neutral pronoun but in in
recent years because of feminism people
have complicated this so in recent Years
you'll sometimes see authors if they're
writing about a neutral person they'll
say you know one does this one does this
she goes down to the store that and
that's kind of jarring you say well she
isn't just traditionally that he is the
neutral pronoun or they'll switch
they'll say he went to the store and
then she did this and he did this and
she did this it's just very very
confusing stick to he it's okay or
better yet stick to the pronouns that
actually describe you maybe I'm more
annoyed about this than I should be but
it feels like extra disrespectful to
misgender somebody when they have a
pronoun pin on like you know I know I'm
comforting I know I look like a girl but
it's right here it's like I have a say
them there pronoun pin right here and
people still call me a girl people are
still using sheer and it's like guys
come on I'm I'm not asking for much here
it's not hard to be respectful of
people's pronouns can we try harder
please be respectful of people says the
woman demanding that everyone else lie
for her just be respectful of people she
said as she demanded that everyone else
in the world said what she wants them to
say and lied about their own perceptions
of reality and tried to conform the
entire universe to her own delusions
just be respectful is it so hard it's
not respectful too it's not respectful
to talk to a person who is schizophrenic
and say hey what are those voices
telling you today oh yeah
oh you're not respectful
you are indulging their delusions but
it's not respectful to do that it's not
respectful to do it to this poor
confused woman it says they them well
unless she's possessed by demons which
she might well be they them would not be
an appropriate pronoun and that they
then would just refer to the demons who
should be exercised out of her person so
in any case not not respectful at all
and I think maybe these very sexually
confused people should have a little
respect for the rest of us who don't
want to be forced to lie all the time to
indulge their very destructive delusions
not a good thing to do all right the
body and the Soul are united and so
we're not just pure soul and we're not
just pure body but when you want your
body to look really good you got to
check out gen you sell people are raving
about genu self skin care Jessica from
Huntsville Alabama says my skin looks so
soft and clear I have seen a reduced
number of fine lines and dark spots I
found a new lifetime product absolutely
love it geniusell was born from its
founder in a small New Jersey town is a
favor to one of his Pharmacy customers
using rare botanic extracts and
scientifically researched ingredients
genucel is uniquely formulated to Target
all visible signs of aging Fine Lines
wrinkles dark spots a sagging jawline
even those puffy under eye bags that I
sometimes deal with because my diet
consists of cigars alcohol and black
coffee the genu cell product you use
today uses the same one-of-a-kind
proprietary flower base developed by its
founder all those years ago wonderful
wonderful founder with a great story
himself all genuine cell products work
for both men and women plus they're safe
for all skin types you are guaranteed to
see immediate results in 12 hours or
your money back I love these guys even
with a hard case like my under eye bags
a geniusell does an absolutely great job
dry gen your cell's most popular package
for 70 off at genucel.com
join millions of happy customers who
have already fallen in love with the
results Plus for a limited time get
Geniuses probiotic extract infused
moisturizer free with every most popular
package subscribing at a complimentary
bonus box Jan usell.com
knowlesgenucl.com Knowles let's keep
going I'm glad you
are heavily based on your culture and
your cultural background not very based
if you ask me
for example I know in Hawaiian culture
there are three genders there's a third
gender uh I forget what it's called I'm
sorry but if you happen to be native
Hawaiian you could identify as that
third gender and then man and woman
or if you happen to be you know from
native Hawaiian background and and on
the other side you have a different
background that also has a third gender
you can identify as those two non-binary
genders
and then take your pick if you want man
or woman or not even another non-binary
gender but all in all it comes from your
cultural background so for me I come
from a very heavy Dutch background and
American background so
for me it's more based on if there's man
on one side woman on the other and
non-binary is somewhere in the middle
and then I take up that whole area the
whole bar there
and I know for a lot of people
non-binary is a completely separate
spectrum and I that's just not my
experience but I still think that that's
a valid experience to have the one thing
she said that's true is that she comes
from a very American culture from a very
extreme leftist part of the American
culture which says that you can be
whatever you want and which purports to
have all this deep understanding of all
of the indigenous cultures around the
world which she manifestly does not
there's this lie that the
transgenderists push that other cultures
indigenous cultures find me the culture
by the way that is not at some point
indigenous aren't all cultures
indigenous at some point in time at the
very least she says certain indigenous
cultures like the Hawaiians and the this
people and that people they have this
concept of a third gender or the
two-spirited gender and it's just
totally Bonkers it's made up it's not
real It's Made Up by white liberal
people to try to give an exotic flavor
and an historical justification for
their absurd fear theories about sex and
gender that that really just developed
in recent decades
and and then this woman says well I'm
somewhere in the middle because I come
from this culture and I know there's
this spectrum and that and she's dressed
up in a way that is not conducive to
flourishing and I I don't know about
this woman's a different psychological
difficulties but it is a in fact the
case that a lot of people who suffer
from the sexual confusion are not
secretly the Opposites ex they're not
even suffering from gender dysphoria
primarily but they're autistic and I
remember I was giving a speech once and
a gal came up to me and she said hey
Michael
um I suffered with the gender confusion
for years and a lot of liberal people in
the world told me that I should try to
pretend to be a man and I should
transition and go through the hormones
and all the rest of it but fortunately I
had a good solid family good solid
church I was a member of and finally I
was just recently diagnosed with autism
and so when doctors stopped trying to
treat my gender dysphoria or my
transgenderism or whatever and started
treating the actual issue that I have
which is autism my problems largely went
away because now I'm receiving the
proper medical treatment and
psychological treatment that I should
receive and I just wonder for people
especially people who have autism or
related conditions to autism who have
trouble picking up on social cues who
have difficulty uh recognizing the way
that Society functions especially
because many man is a social animal man
is a political animal and we exist in
society with one another if a lot of the
alienation the alienation not only from
society but from one's own body and
one's own identity it just comes from
those sorts of psychological problems
and and so the the less that we treat
that the real underlying issue in a lot
of cases the more that we indulge this
kind of behavior and then all of the
pathologies just get worse that's it
okay what's my what's my favorite
pronoun Tick Tock the first one for
without any question the first one was
the best by far because it just showed
you where this all leads to it shows you
that I in a conversation could call
myself you or I could call myself we or
we could call yourself the walrus and it
doesn't have to do with sex or gender or
Identity or this abstraction or this
abstraction of the abstraction evil de
Gobbledy chicken
a little
no that's the conclusion the conclusion
is just chaos and cacophony see you next
time
[Music]